Scarlett Johansson becomes the love
child of Deathstroke and dr. Manhattan
that's it
Lucy so Lucy is a story or a movie I
don't know that I call it a story it's
not really much of one in the movie Lucy
is a movie written and directed by Luc
Besson in which Scarlett Johansson we
know she's a badass we know she can do
cool [ __ ] there's this new super drug
out there not a lot of people know what
it does but she gets a super dose of it
now she's on the road to unlocking 100%
of her brain capacity that means really
cool [ __ ] can happen because of our
hundred percent we use ten and
sequential he starts out you know twenty
percent she's really smart she can do
cool [ __ ] 30 percent she can do more 40
percent she can do more that's kind of
the movie more or less you can argue
that the plot is that she needs more of
the drug so she has to go and find these
drug mules who are smuggling it but it's
not really that that's a small part of
it ultimately the movie exists so you
can see her do cool [ __ ] as her brain
capacity starts unlocking and that you
see her do really cool [ __ ] and that is
entertaining you see you're thumbing
through [ __ ] she's reading things super
fast she's typing on two different
laptops with two different hands at the
same time this movie reminds me of what
my friends and I used to do we used to
sit around it you know restaurant or
something we used to brainstorm cool
things we'd like to see in a movie but
we had no clear way to put it into a
movie did we write a script for it no we
did not how would we put it into a movie
I have no idea it'd just be cool to see
that [ __ ] in movies my friends and I
when we movie nerd out we moving nerd
out there's like a look Besson and his
friends they're sitting around they were
like oh I'd be cool to see a movie where
someone starts unlocking their brain
capacity it's like 100% psycho wait have
it start out as 10 and 15 and in 20 30
40 50 yeah and then you can sequential
II see it unlocker and she can start
doing [ __ ] she's reading fast at first
all right maybe she's moving things with
her mind or what else did you yeah you
could could you read people's minds
maybe and they came up with this thing
that they would like to see in a movie
and then luc besson was like I'd better
write it then and now we have this movie
I mean the movie starts out kind of
sloppy not gonna lie you see Scarlett
Johansson she's arguing with her really
sleazy boyfriend and then it has these
really weird clips and I get the
parallels of the clip so it's like oh
she's being baited into doing something
and then it cuts to a clip of a little
mouse going to a mousetrap having cheese
on it and I'm like what is that why is
that in there then people are coming for
her they're closing in on her and then
it shows National Geographic footage of
this cheetah stalking something I get
the parallels like Oh human nature is
animalist
it hasn't changed animals are like us we
were like animals but now we're going to
evolve past it doesn't mean it doesn't
feel completely out of place in this
movie because it's used at the beginning
and it's never used again ever like in
the editing room they were like do you
want to keep this I say we stop and they
stopped but they kept what they put in
there's even this cop that she teams up
with in the movie and the dude says the
most logical thing in the entire movie
after seeing her clear out of room he's
like I don't think I could be much help
to you and she's like you are you're a
reminder she might as well have turn to
the screen and said what she really
meant you are I'm a super smart
emotionally distant robot at this point
the audience needs someone to relate to
and that ain't me I mean how much can
you relate to a character that really
has no threats early on in the movie
when she walks into a room it goes Bam
Bam Bam it just clears everyone out and
she digs the bullet out of her arm
without feeling any pain and that's at
like 20 percent of her brain capacity
yeah it just goes up from there at a
point you're like you're she God why do
I care the truth is you don't I think
luc besson knew that that's what i mean
when i say he just wanted to see cool
[ __ ] in a movie and he put really cool
[ __ ] in the movie but in terms of a plot
of a movie you don't care about the
characters you don't really care where
it's going the movie exists for the cool
things that happen cuz Lucy would
probably be a great time if you're drunk
yeah a no is a party ever I can use a
hundred percent of my brain capacity
don't try it at home no delusions of
grandeur that's not 100 percent of your
brain so if you can use more of your
brain capacity what would you do with it
whatever you do comment below let me
know that's right guys right now as
you're watching this I'm at San Diego
Comic Con so if you're there dude just
be on my Twitter follow me on twitter
I'll be tweeting I'll be like I am here
I'm there I'm at this booth if you see
me say hi I love meeting fans
yeah and short I won't be able to review
Hercules until I get back I know I know
you're dying to see me review that one I
really thank you for your patience in
these times of uncertainty royal as I'm
down in comic-con probably having a
little bit of fun that's why you guys
kick ass and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you